18 brumè en 8 Napoléon Bonaparte au
commande des troupes de la capitale
prend le contrôle du château de
saint-clou où sont réuni le Conseil des
500 et les anciens objectif obtenir des
députés la fin du directoire et une
nouvelle Constitution dans le même temps
au Palais du Luxembourg les chefs du
directoire sont contraints de quitter
leur fonction c'est au cœur même de ce
palais que se prépare en secret depuis
plusieurs mois le coup d'État et son
succès lira à jamais le destin du futur
empereur à celui du Palais du
Luxembourg le 19 brumer la fin du
directoire est proclamée l'exécutif est
alors confié à trois consuls provisoires
dont Napoléon celui-ci avec sa femme
Joséphine quitte alors son hôtel
parisien pour le petit
Luxembourg il se dit même que c'est ici
qu'ils se sont rencontrés la première
fois au cours d'une réception depuis son
son bureau celui qu'utiliserait encore
aujourd'hui le président du Sénat
Napoléon imagine alors une nouvelle
constitution qu'il parvient faire
accepter après de longues négociations
celle-ci fait de lui le Premier Consul
disposant de l'essentiel du pouvoir elle
crée également le Sénat
conservateur conservateur parce que le
Sénat a pour mission de veiller à la
constitutionnalité des actes des autres
assemblées le Corps législatif le
Conseil d'État et le tribunal le Sénat
devient une chambre fondatrice du
système conçu par Napoléon et lui permet
de conserver un certain contrôle sur le
pouvoir
législatif fin février 1800 Napoléon
rejoint les Tuileries et remet le palais
au Sénat conservateur
entre 1804 et 1852 les sénateurs se
réunissent au centre de l'actuelle salle
des conférences deux hémicycles se font
face dans le plus vaste siège les
sénateurs dans le plus petit se trouve
le trône de l'empereur
c'est dans cette salle le 18 mai 1804
que Napoléon Bonaparte est proclamé
empereur des
Français l'ombre de Napoléon est
toujours présente aujourd'hui au Sénat
avec la garde républicaine et le trône
venez les découvrir lors des prochaines
Journées européennes du
patrimoine